foreign
[Music]
that's life
as a war
there's a fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
my name came back the past came back too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back no friends
[Music]
before I got locked up I was the best
you coward bro and a fraud try to
spending half your life in a Cell
watching somebody else live your life
getting started little brother out
between my brothers and my enemies
I'm coming for it all
it's not gonna stop
and you make it
the one and only Adonis Creed you're the
best pound fighter in the world three
years ago it's been a minute since
you've been out in these streets when I
walked away from boxing I walked away
with some unfinished business
[Music]
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey hey
no friends in the industry I had to draw
the line between my brothers and my
enemies are back
yeah you hit us up and now we always
let them destroy everything you've found
everything we've built yeah
start fighting
[Music]